palme d'or mais parle du hall gauche
tout revient à repartis de cannes avec
les plus grands honneurs parasites
engranger jusqu'à maintenant plus de 90
millions de dollars de recettes
c'est un film qui a cette vertu d'avoir
réuni le beurre et l'argent du beurre
donc effectivement une réussite
populaire une réussite critique c'est un
peu la marque de commerce de banques
john aux médias le film raconte
l'histoire d'une famille de chômeurs qui
à force de magouilles réussi à
s'incruster parasiter la vie d'une
famille riche je dirais la prémisse
pourrait ressembler au bout en deux par
la famille de ces séries qui fait des
combines pour se sortir de la misère et
peut-être une rupture de ton qu'une
descente aux enfers qui pourrait
s'apparenter à chapeau jack hannahan 0
jonway du cinéma hollywoodien parasites
surprend des routes qui captive comédie
noire est un film d'horreur et un
passage de l'un à l'autre qui est quand
même assez étonnant chez lui ou si un
souci de dire quelque chose dans son
septième long métrage le réalisateur
vedette bangolo met en scène une société
inégalitaire où il est vrai ni les
pauvres ne sont tout bon ou tout mauvais
en fait on pourrait dire de parasites
que c'est l'antidote ont abaissé de
rester chacun à sa place de port
bousculer l'ordre établi
non seulement le bouscule mais quand on
le fait c'est parfois de façon sauvage
qui rend demain la réput 1 autant que le
cinéma de bong joon ho très souvent de
contrat en même temps c'est souvent des
préoccupations sont universelles et le
cinéma coréen en particulier celui de
boeck journaux et fait aussi pour plaire
à un public international
comme avec la crypte up les autorités
sud-coréennes soit utilisé leur
cinématographie pour rayonner à
l'étranger cinématographie à surveiller
un qui est en pleine transformation et
parce que les films sont solides mais
aussi parce qu'on a pris des mesures
fermes pour lui réserver une place dans
les salles de cinéma
gageons que nous entendrons encore par
les parasites puisque après cannes le
film pourrait bien s'illustrer aux
oscars ici n'est dit alexandre charti
radio canada montréal